yeah hello and welcome to this video Joe
Lucas same one yep never played him
let's zoom here Queens Indian or you can
also always get a hedgehog or double
fianchetto yep the drupal p NK now black
has very good equalizing chances in this
opening line what doesn't have much I
mean rather than nothing nothing at all
conserve one day in flag 9427 King takes
95 check and wide wins apiece yeah
normal is just to take on g2
it can also place a 60 home see a door
some static fatiha on flexible
okay um let's go 95 you cannot take on
default on these five if you basically
has to play with 88 now f e8 I can take
and play 97 so that was the only move
which I probably cannot really exploit
this in some way that it looks a bit
awkward there but it's probably no way
to to do something about it
[Music]
so some of you is a bit easier for wine
so we are nine ticks on Pont eggs I
think I'll take with the pawn that gives
me some ideas with the six square
maybe he goes 8 9 a-5 95 with that
weakens also a little bit now it's not
so easy for him
hmm I would love to get the knight to c6
night c 2 and so on
can prevent this 95 okay can you have to
next stopping 95 he might move the king
and try to put the night on to f6 and
you for that's possible
the move whoopsie six no we had 95 but
Luke c6 now gets a bit more interesting
maybe oh it's not something I expected
95 I cannot play unfortunately for the
Bible night c4 in this position d 5 this
idea is Knight f6 34 if he get that in
he is okay
[Music]
I cannot do much about this angling for
95 or night c 2 to the form it's
probably just equal
night beside it a little bit more
threatening so check here or 97 and 97
King be six so it doesn't do all that
much okay Ruby six now oops is set up
super c6 now
okay okay oh this one I didn't see that
that's it stupid of course that's a good
move I just didn't see it time warning
and all the sudden he's more active in
this position yeah ma'am awful really
awful to get into into trouble here Jeff
yeah there's this one single move cost
me the game this check and overlooking
that there that you can step forward
instead of backward yeah this this was
the big issue Jeff Jeff Jeff okay so I'm
not losing any more girl a third okay
then I'm going to try to win on time
okay okay I don't offer five times check
check black 46 on time damn that it was
that was really stupid check on the six
I did not see King see fire at all i
think the form it was always some young
equal issue I know maybe I had something
some some some slight thing going for me
but I don't I didn't see anything I
didn't see anything I'm not a huge fan
of f5 but it seems to be okay yeah this
looks strange of it have quasi Brooks is
6 I was just thinking okay I take it his
deep on this week and so on the drugs is
16 that makes a lot of sense okay the
engine doesn't give me much but still it
made sense
yeah this is not dangerous really am
it's got discovered difficult to improve
this gym and this was absolutely nothing
okay yeah okay Ruby 6 is wrong I thought
he has to go back to e7 I just did not
see an King c5 and here this is
immediate trouble okay the engine
doesn't even give me a huge disadvantage
but I was so pissed that I've squandered
it even more way the snow is losing okay
okay can I have to check continue I can
of course very easily there with the
deep one no Ruby five or so is equal
yeah King f2 is a lot better yet seems
rook see to a form and if Black gets
this the engine indicates you get this
counter play down yeah sure that should
be a draw ultimately yeah I completely
in this together king suffice ok guys
thanks for watching